[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 europe une
émission enregistrée ici au parlement
européen à strasbourg notre invité pour
cette émission et aymeric chauprade euro
députés non inscrits ancienne tête de
liste du front national pour l'île de
france
ensemble nous évoquerons l'actualité de
son ancien parti l'attention
commerciales et diplomatiques qui monte
entre l'union européenne les etats-unis
mais aussi le reste du monde
comme à chaque fois nous vous
présenterons aussi le parcours d'un père
fondateur du vieux continent l'italien
atyrau spinelli et en fin d'émission il
sera question d'euthanasie sujet
complexe et propice au débat nous
verrons les choix qu'ont fait nos
voisins européens entre interdiction
totale et droit de donner la mort
[Musique]
aymeric chauprade bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes eurodéputé depuis 2014 initialement
membres du front national ici vous
n'êtes plus membre du du fn depuis 2015
sur fond de tensions avec sa présidente
marine le pen vous êtes aujourd'hui non
inscrits au parlement européen en clair
vous n'appartenait à aucun groupe
politique
est ce que vous diriez que c'est un
avantage car ça vous donne plus
d'indépendance ou alors c'est quand même
des difficultés puisque je crois savoir
que vous ne pouvez pas être l'auteur de
deux rapports par exemple est-ce que
c'est un avantage vous plutôt d un
inconvénient d'être non inscrits au
parlement européen l'indépendance la
liberté c'est toujours un avantage bien
sûr parce qu'on défend véritablement ses
convictions et intégralement ses
convictions mais ça évidemment aussi des
limites les limites sont des limites
politiques il est évident que il est
plus facile d'être réélu quand vous
appartenait à une famille politique ou
un groupe politique
donc ça dépend de l'objectif qui sera le
mien en 2019 soit revenir à la vie
civile moi je suis un élément encore
mais elles n'ont pas encore non je suis
un élu de la vie civile
la société civile
ou bien continuer mais il faut que ça
fasse sens par rapport à mon engagement
politique
c'est mon engagement politique il a été
fondé sur la question de la civilisation
l'avenir de la civilisation française et
européenne c'est ce qui me préoccupe
mais c'est aussi la réforme de la france
la réforme économique et social qui qui
m'intéressent on en parlera ouais pour
pour l'anecdote vous êtes non inscrits
ici comme comme jean marie le pen
comment vous regardez sa mise à l'écart
du front national est ce que vous êtes
vous resté plus ou moins proche du
fondateur du fn
non je n'ai pas jamais été un proche
j'ai de bonnes relations avec lui mais
j'ai jamais été un proche du fondateur
du front national
vous savez mon mon expérience au front
national elle est très courte c'est
c'est un an et demi je ne la renie pas
du tout parce qu'elle m'a appris
beaucoup
d'abord elle m'a permis c'est vrai aussi
devait être élu évidemment et je
n'oublie pas d'entrer dans la vie
politique et parce que ce sont tous ces
français qui sont et qui se vivent comme
les perdants de la mondialisation et qui
me préoccupe moi ce qui m'intéresse en
fait c'est pas de travailler pour les
gagnons la mondialisation ou contre les
gagnants de la mondialisation c'est de
faire en sorte que les perdants de la
mondialisation deviennent des gagnants
voilà c'est ce que j'aimerais alors
pourquoi j'ai quitté le front national
c'est très simple donc s'il ya plusieurs
raisons j'ai résumé assez à serra très
très brièvement
il ya plusieurs raisons la première
c'est que le front national n'est pas ce
qu'il dit être il y a toujours un noyau
dur de gens radicaux qui malheureusement
font du tort au front national vont les
tailleurs au front national ça c'est
certain qu'ils représentent pas
l'opinion d'une l'immense majorité des
électeurs du front national et même des
cadres mais qui sont disons le
antisémites qu'il le reste et puis le
front national fait beaucoup de bêtises
ici au parlement j'ai refusé de
m'associer à cela j'ai donc pas été mise
en examen j'ai pas été soupçonné dans la
sphère des assistants j'ai refusé ce que
marine le pen me demandait de faire et
j'ai bien fait de le refuser
donc j'ai eu avec ce parti beaucoup de
différent et j'ai une autre lecture que
cette du front national de ce qui se
passe dans le cadre de la mondialisation
va on va en reparler du front national
aussi dans quelques instants le ou
plutôt le futur rassemblement national b
d'abord découvrons celles et ceux qui
ont participé à la construction
européenne sur moi aussi altiero
spinelli
cet italien fut un fervent partisan du
fédéralisme européen son parcours avec
philippe le guen le directeur de
l'association jean monnet basée à
bazoches sur guyonne
[Musique]
or altiero spinelli c'est un homme
politique italien qui est née au début
du siècle et qui a été un homme de
gauche et opposants de la première heure
au fascisme et à mussolini ce qui lui a
valu d'être emprisonné d'abord et
ensuite est mis en résidence pendant
toute la période fasciste sur une île
nous très petite île au large de
l'italie qui s'appelle ventotene et qui
aujourd'hui connue puisque il a rédigé
depuis cette île avec ses amis
emprisonnés comme lui le manifeste de
ventotene pour l'europe unie et fédéral
donc il a eu très tôt l'idée de qu'il
fallait créer une fédération européenne
pour éviter de nouveaux conflits et pour
éviter les guerres donc par la suite il
a joué un rôle après la guerre comme en
politique italien et puis il s'est
retrouvé aussi à la commission
européenne comme commissaire et depuis
par la suite il a été élu au parlement
européen
est resté dix ans il a eu un rôle
important pour lancer des réformes
institutionnelles du parlement européen
j'ai été la charge des femmes qui a été
se parle d'un instant t c'est un fait à
présent il faut le faire dit il a réussi
à convaincre en particulier d'autres
députés qui n'était pas forcément que le
aussi visionnaire que lui 2
de rejoindre sa position qui était de
dire qu'il fallait que le parlement
européen joue beaucoup plus le rôle
d'une instance fédérale puisque c'était
son idée
il voulait une fédération même si au fil
du temps il a compris qu'on n'aurait pas
des états unis fédéraux rapidement en
tout cas il fallait que le parlement
européen joue un rôle très important
notamment dans le dans la validation du
budget européen et ça a été un des grand
réformateur du parlement européen ce qui
lui a valu d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
d'avoir un bâtiment du parlement
européen bruxelles qui porte son nom
donc c'est quelqu'un qui est peu connue
finalement en france il est assez connue
en italie pour son appel de 20 hôtels et
de 1941 et s'éteint il est à l'origine
du mouvement fédéraliste européen
puisqu'il a créé très tôt ce mouvement
ni de à partir de l'italie et qui est
devenu ensuite internationale
[Musique]
aymeric chauprade en lien avec la
découverte à l'instant de l'histoire de
monsieur spinelli hommes politiques
italiens comment vous regardez vous
l'actualité actuellement politique
italienne on s'est rendu compte
finalement que lorsque la droite et
l'extrême droite
sally il y as possibilité d'être d'être
en tête des élections c'est en tout cas
ce qui s'est passé en italie avec 37%
des voix réunies alors ça va être
difficile de former un gouvernement
c'est différent de la france mais est ce
que ça ça doit donner et des idéaux aux
politiques français à la droite
française et au front national peut être
pour envisager des alliances dans l'est
dans les futures élections
ce qu'il faut regarder c'est ce qui se
passe en europe si ces types de
gouvernement arrivent au pouvoir c'est
le cas aussi en autriche on parle de
l'italie mais il y a le cas de
l'autriche ce type de coalition c'est
parce que la question de l'identité la
question de la civilisation et donc de
l'immigration n'est pas traitée au plan
européen les peuples
de l'europe veulent l'europe je pense qu
il sauf ils ne sont pas contre la
construction européenne contre l'union
européenne mais ils sont contre à juste
titre la perte de leur civilisation
et c'est cette angoisse qui est exprimée
par ses votes qu'on appelle populiste et
c est donc ici on prend pas ça en compte
et bien on aura une vague de ce type de
gouvernement au niveau européen moi ce
que je souhaite c'est pas une alliance
avec des partis radicaux pour être passé
au front national je sais pourquoi il ne
faut pas s'allier avec le front national
aujourd'hui
donc vous dites que l air n'a pas n'a
pas d'intérêt contrairement à thierry
mariani je pense que les outils
récemment anciens en ciment thierry
mariani n'est pas passé au front
national contrairement à moi donc il ne
s'est pas véritablement de quoi il parle
et c'est sans doute pour ça qu'il ne se
rend pas compte qu'il n'ya pas lieu de
faire une alliance avec le front
national ce qu'il faut c'est refonder la
droite faire un parti de droite crédible
assumer capable de récupérer et de
ramener à lui les électeurs qui votent
aujourd'hui front national car le front
national est une impasse et il faut le
dire il faut expliquer pourquoi c'est
une impasse mais en tout cas je crois
pas du tout à ce type de coalition
et puis la situation l'italie et de
l'autriche étudiants elles sont chacune
spécifique la liga c'est pas le front
national le fph en autriche c'est pas le
front national d'ailleurs le fpm n'est
pas aussi anti européen que le front
national en france vous vous diriez
aujourd'hui qu'il ya un risque
civilisationnel en france et si oui
comment comment il s'applique
concrètement selon mais le risque
civilisationnel c'est la question de
l'islam radical
le l'islam politique bien évidemment
il faudrait être aveugle pour ne pas
voir que cette idéologie islamique
progresse dans la population dans la
communauté musulmane et même au delà
avec des convertis c'était évidemment
contraire à nos valeurs
c'est incompatible vous savez la france
c'est pas exagérer ce risque-là
aujourd'hui non il n'est pas exagéré
c'est une réalité qui à la fois
identitaire il y à une idéologie qui se
propage dans le monde qui d'ailleurs
transforme aussi le monde arabe
parce que le monde arabe a été plus haut
davantage laïcisé dans les années 60 70
et on voit aujourd'hui qu'il est un
retour à ce fondamentalisme partout et
la france est en danger d'islam radical
c'est une réalité enterrement c'est le
mot selon vous à débattre parce que
l'erreur serait de voir uniquement la
dimension terroriste la dimension
criminelle et de ne pas voir la
dimension politique
quand je dis un danger c'est que nous
français nous venons de philosophie nous
sommes issus de philosophie différente
qui depuis toujours ont cohabité avec
des religions différents et qu'ils sont
compatibles parce que nous partageons
dans la république des valeurs qui nous
sont communes
mais l'idéologie islamique porté par les
frères musulmans par tout un tas
d'associations musulmanes
ça c'est incompatible avec la république
et ça c'est pas le même projet de
civilisation que nous alors on va parler
maintenant de l'union européenne et puis
des affaires du monde vous êtes un
spécialiste de la géopolitique auteur de
plusieurs ouvrages là-dessus membres au
parlement européen de la commission des
affaires étrangères
la tension monte ces derniers temps d'un
point de vue commercial entre donald
trump le reste du monde donc l'union
européenne
certains parlent de guerre commerciale
depuis la mise en place de taxes sur
l'acier l'alu l'aluminium ça fait la une
des médias
est ce que le mot de guerre commerciale
et là aussi justifier ou alors c'est
exagéré de parler de guerre commerciale
mais je crois qu'il faut confirmer un
coup de com clairement on sait je crois
qu'il faut comprendre que
donald trump incarne avec d'autres
leaders forts dans le monde ce qu'est le
nouveau monde multipolaire c'est un
monde d'état d'état qui défendent leurs
intérêts géopolitiques et commerciaux de
manière parfois unilatérale de manière
parfois brutales et c'est tout le
malentendu qui lie avec l'union
européenne l'union européenne a une
vision passé harmonique des choses assez
même angélique et l'union européenne etc
le problème n'est pas une puissance donc
l'union européenne aujourd'hui n'est pas
armés parce qu'elle n'est pas l'europe
puissance pour affronter cette ses
échanges commerciaux avec les états unis
vous vous a plu par exemple un
durcissement du ton l'union européenne
par exemple doit rendre coup pour coup
il est évident bien sûr il est évident
que donald trump n'a pas vocation à
calmer le jeu par exemple on est
justement peut-être se mettre au dessus
du débat est nommé temps déclenché ces
graines commercial ton vous mais 25% sur
l'acier 10% sur la lune il y avait que
donald attend cette réponse là justement
généraux c'est ce que c'est pas un piège
qui nous attend si c'est une vision on
parle de dealmakers sais ce que c'est
quelqu'un qui négocient qui d'ailleurs
associe des dossiers il est capable de
dire en même temps à l'alena au mexique
et au canada
ah bah écoute et peut-être que pour vous
on va faire des exemptions mais alors
reparlons du traité de l'alena donc
c'est quelqu'un qui défend les intérêts
commerciaux des états une manière
brutale
il n'y a aucune raison de lui faire de
cadeau il faut donc répondre évidemment
il s'agit pas d' abîmer nos relations
avec les états unis mais après tout
quand on reçoit des coups on est en
mesure de répondre aussi et je crois que
très franchement répondent uniquement
sur le bourbon le beurre de cacahuète
les jeans lewis c'est un peu court quand
on parle de d'exportation de l'union
européenne 2
de plusieurs milliards vers vers les
états unis ça pourrait coûter 3
milliards d'euros à peu près par exemple
à l'industrie française
bien sûr c'est pas rien c'est pas rien
déjà que vous savez quand on compare on
est patient concerné mais comment vous
est venue trêve ces sondes et
l'allemagne qui a visé la chine est
devenue bien sûr prédominante dans le
domaine de l'acier de l'aluminium mais
mais quand même il n'y a aucune raison
pour accepter que les états unis tordent
les principes de l omc et répondent
seulement devant l'organe de règlement
des différends le rd c'est pas suffisant
d'abord parce qu'il ya des délais qui
sont trop longs il faut dès maintenant
avoir des mesures de rétorsion
équivalente significative face aux
mesures prises par donald trump
ça c'est le devoir de l'europe pour que
l'europe soit respectée qu'elle se fasse
respecter comme puissance commerciale
sur la scène internationale elle doit
répondre
que pensez-vous de federica mot guérini
qui est aujourd'hui on va vulgariser son
poste elle est officiellement haute
représentante de l'union pour les
affaires étrangères et la politique de
sécurité
en clair c'est notre ministre des
affaires étrangères européennes qu'est
ce que vous pensez de cette commissaire
est ce que vous pensez qu'elle est de
taille justement pour peut-être répondre
à donald trump pour répondre aussi à
vladimir poutine à xi jinping en chine
vous savez il s'agit pas d'une question
de personnes d'abord j'ai du respect de
l'estimé pour madame monique qui connaît
son sujet qui est une femme courageuse
et qui se base sur les dossiers de
l'union européenne en tant qu il arrive
à 24 ans jay se sont se sont méfiés de
daegu t il son arrivée bien qu'étant
bien qu'étant à l'époque au front
national et j'ai toujours observer la
plus grande prudence et la plus grande
courtoisie à son égard car je respecte
son parcours je respecte ses engagements
mais le problème n'est pas federica mot
guérini le problème c'est que l'union
européenne devienne une puissance et
pour ça il faut une réforme et j'attends
beaucoup du président macron pour
impulser cette réforme profonde de
l'europe une rom c'est à dire sur quoi
par exemple
du mode de fonctionnement de l'union
européenne souligne justement cette
nouvelle union européenne par exemple
d'abord le constat si les peuples vote
autant contre l'union européenne comme
ils le font le vote pour emmanuel macron
ce n'est pas un vote contre l'union
européenne ça pourrait être pris comme
un vote pour l'union européenne c'est
vrai mais oui vous angela merkel s'est
elle n'a pas échappé que le front
national a quand même été au deuxième
tour d'une élection présidentielle en
france et que vous évitez la leur voilà
on a des scores assez la liga norte
maintenant possiblement au pouvoir en
italie le fp en autriche etc
donc ça veut dire soyons lucides qu'il y
a un problème avec l'union européenne
que les peuples expriment et si nous ne
réformons pas l'union européenne en
profondeur alors c'est tout l'édifice
européen qui s'effondrera d'un coup et
nous reviendrons en arrière et ce sera
dommageable ça n'est pas ce que je
souhaite je ne veux pas de fric site je
pense que le bric site est regrettable
et qu'il va compliquer d'ailleurs la
relation avait entre le royaume uni et
l'union européenne ont ce qu'il faut
c'est c'est assez complexe parce que
c'est à la fois respecter les
différences qui existent entre les états
je les forme de l'union européenne c'est
moins de laisser plus de une part de sa
souveraineté finalement au vieux
continent est ce qu'il faut accepter de
perdre par exemple son pouvoir sur sa
politique et rivières sachant que la
france a une politique étrangère
importante on le sait la principale de
l'union européenne
alors c'est d'abord une solution qui est
flexible et adaptée aux souhaits des
différentes nations il y a du côté de
l'europe de l'est des nations comme la
pologne qui manifestement ne veulent pas
accélérer l'intégration qui ainsi sur
leurs spécificités otanienne et donc ne
veulent pas de défense européenne il y a
en revanche à l'ouest des nations qui
veulent s'intégrer davantage
je pense qu'il faut créer la possibilité
que un noyau dur de pays puisse
accélérer l'intégration y compris
économique monétaire elle existe avec la
zone euro et d'un goût
arnaud mans économique de l'europe et
qui respecte en même temps la volonté
des autres partenaires de l'union
d'avancé à leur vitesse avec leurs
spécificités
aujourd'hui on pensait que les 28 ce
manque clairement se font croire qu'ils
vont avancer ensemble
c'est aussi une fois que tu es une
scission s'est passé pas une scission
parce que je pense que nous sommes un
club à 28 pays 27 peut-être demain si le
royaume uni par c'est admettre qu'il
faut une fille une flexibilité et que
les pays de l'union européenne doivent
pouvoir avancer à la vitesse à laquelle
ils veulent avancer et sur les priorités
qui se sont fixés si nous ne faisons pas
ça si nous n'inventons pas cette
flexibilité est bien ça s'effondrera
en clair jeudi que le président macron a
raison de vouloir accélérer le processus
d'intégration au niveau l'eurozone de la
raison l'eurozone mais qu'en revanche je
comprends la préoccupation des pays
d'europe de l'est de la hongrie de la
pologne qui le s'interroge sur l'absence
de politique migratoire et l'absence de
contrôle en matière d'immigration de
flux migratoires au sein de l'union
européenne on en vient maintenant à
notre rubrique et chez nos voisins ça se
passe comment en france l'euthanasie
dite active est toujours interdite mais
la loi autorise la sédation profonde et
continue jusqu'au décès du passion seuls
les malades en phase terminale peuvent
en bénéficier c'est l'un des thèmes de
réflexion des états généraux de la
bioéthique en ce moment en france qu'en
est il ailleurs en europe on fait le
point avec olivier jeanne l'ex
responsable du centre europe direct à
saint germain en laye
[Musique]
le premier pays qui a légalisé
l'euthanasie et les pays bas les
conditions sont assez simple il faut que
le patient soit dans une situation
médicale qui soit critiqué sans issue et
notamment qu'il en ait fait la demande
les deux autres pays qui sont concernés
par l'euthanasie donc qu'ils sont aussi
donc ils sont la belgique et le
luxembourg
c'est aussi on va dire c'est aussi
grosso modo les mêmes conditions c'est à
chaque fois il faut que la personne soit
dense y est dans une situation médicale
qu'ils soient sans issue possible et
qu'elle en ait fait la demande
alors après concrètement sur qui peut
faire la demande spécifiquement est
ainsi depuis là quelques petites
variations et pour que l'hôpital accepte
ou pas d'accorder l'euthanasie valais
les prises de décisions peuvent être
dits le peuvent être différentes en
fonction des pays il ya certains pays où
c'est strictement interdit et si on
pratiquer une euthanasie notamment les
médecins peuvent être pénalement
condamné
c'est notamment le cas de la grèce de la
pologne et de l'irlande
si on prend par exemple le cas de la
grèce on peut avoir une peine de prison
qui va jusqu'à 7 ans de prison
en irlande toute forme d'assistance à la
mort peut aller jusqu'à 14 en prison on
a des peines qui sont assez dissuasive
et là c'est strictement interdite
d'autres pays sont beaucoup plus souples
dans le sens tout dépend en fait de ce
qu'on entend par route par euthanasie en
fait on a atteint l'asie active dans le
sang selon l'âge est qd un produit dont
une qui provoque la mort de la personne
et on a aussi eu des nazis passive qui
grosso modo correspond au fait de ne
plus accorder de traitement afin de
maintenir la personne en vie et donc
dans le cadre dans le cas d'euthanasie
passive
on a certains pays qui autorisent
justement cette tanaisie passif
on a notamment le cas du danemark de
langres y ait de la république tchèque
et dans ces pays l'aps et les patients
qui demandent tout simplement à ne plus
être victime d'acharnement thérapeutique
[Musique]
aymeric chauprade l'euthanasie est un
sujet on le sait évidemment sensible et
ce quel que soit le bord politique le
débat a été relancé par des députés
récemment qu'ils ont demandé à aller
plus loin que la loi claisse leonetti de
2016 quel est votre d'autres comme on
dit que non et c'est une loi suffisantes
actuellement vous quelle est votre
position est ce qu'il faut autoriser
comme en belgique ou aux pays bas
ou alors est-ce qu'il faut interdire
strictement comme en pologne roumanie
par exemple vous avez là aussi on a une
fracture à un précieux sur les questions
de l'eau située sur les questions de
société questions sociétales je suis
très prudent et j'ai c'est le plus
possible de faire la différence la
distinction entre mes convictions
personnelles philosophique et
leur traduction politique pourquoi parce
que je pense que la société évolue sur
un certain nombre de sujets qu'il faut
en tenir compte mais en même temps qu'il
faut pas tomber dans la pente facile de
l'individualisme du matérialisme qui
nous amène finalement à s'autoriser à
faire tout et n'importe quoi et à
considérer que l'être humain est une
marchandise la marchandisation de l'être
humain c'est quelque chose que je
combats sur l'euthanasie
c'est une expérience très très complexe
parce que d'abord j'ai la chance de pas
avoir eu à me poser dans ma famille est
dans mon entourage encore cette question
et c'est pour ça que je suis très
prudent pour pour vous répondre je suis
pas favorable aux modèles d'euthanasie
assumé du suisse belgique et ces médias
l'interdiction je suis ouvert à une
discussion et à
il ya une discussion un débat sur sur le
sujet dernier module de cette émission
la question d'un élu local qui voient ça
qui vous interpellent d'excusé ou en
qualité d'eurodéputés sur la
problématique de son choix je vous
propose de regarder c'est sur la
tablette
il s'agit d'une députée de la république
en marche pour garder bonjour marie le
bec député de la 4e circonscription des
yvelines membre de la commission des
affaires économiques et présidente du
groupe d'études sur l'export et
d'attractivité
j'ai une question à poser sur l'union
européenne et notamment dans le cadre
des traités commerciaux internationaux
on sait que l on attend les mandats de
négociation sur la nouvelle zélande et
l'australie
ou est-ce que ça en est et les
parlementaires nationaux souhaiterait
être davantage associés à la réflexion
afin de lever les inquiétudes et
d'inciter les entreprises à se saisir
des opportunités qu en est-il merci je
ne sais pas si vous connaissez
précisément ces sujets puisque vous êtes
à la commission des affaires étrangères
mine de rien ces accords internationaux
s'interrogent de plus en plus de
personnes notamment pour le manque de
transparence les parlementaires
nationaux qui ne seraient pas au courant
mais aussi sur les conséquences que cela
peut avoir sur l'environnement sur sur
l'emploi sur des secteurs qui sont
fragiles industrielles agricoles ou
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à ces
accords internationaux comme dix
ouvrages vous savez moi je suis
comme je le suis en géopolitique un
réaliste c'est à dire un pragmatique je
n'ai pas d'opposition de principe au
libre échange mais il y à des sujets des
moments où il faut être capable de faire
du protectionnisme est donald trump le
fait sur un certain nombre de domaines
parce qu'ils considèrent pour l'acier
l'aluminium qu'une nation qui ne sait
plus produire ces bâtiments laval ces
voitures sans son acier n'est plus tout
à fait une nation je crois qu'il faut ne
pas avoir d' approche pragmatique ce qui
est certain c'est que la mondialisation
et il ya une tendance de fond est et un
démantèlement progressif des tarifs
douaniers des barrières tarifaires et
même non tarifaires et ça veut dire que
les pays doivent s'adapter à la
mondialisation est la principale
priorité de la france ça n'est pas de
remettre des barrières douanières c'est
de s'adapter d'être compétitive
suffisamment dans la mondialisation
maintenant il faut quand même pas être
naïf
c'est très difficile d'être compétitif
face à la chine et à l'inde qui dresse
sans un certain nombre de deux de normes
sociales environnementales et c'est donc
encore une fois c'est un équilibre je
suis les sujets de libre échange
l'australie et la nouvelle zélande j'ai
voté en faveur du libre-échange parce
que je considère que les pays qui ont
des niveaux de développement équivalent
au nôtre et c'est le cas de l'australie
et la nouvelle-zélande avec ces pays
nous pouvons démontrer un certain nombre
de barrières je suis beaucoup plus
réticent évidemment sur le libre échange
avec des pays en voie de développement
ou émergents
déjà en partie développer parce que ces
pays n'ont pas les mêmes normes sociales
ni environnementale
merci aymeric chauprade d'avoir
participé à ce 7 8 europe je rappelle
que vous êtes heureux députés non
inscrits d'île de france vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
notre site internet est là commenté sur
nos réseaux sociaux tv soixante dix huit
la semaine prochaine vous retrouver le
7-8 politique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là